[ __ ] paix des [ __ ] qu'ils soient
scandés ou afficher les propos
homophobes sont bien ancrées dans les
tribunes des stades de foot
la première prise de parole d'une grande
personnalité contre l'homophobie
c'était en 2006 vikash dhorasoo le
joueur de l'équipe de france a accepté
d'être le parrain du paris football gay
club qui lutte contre l'homophobie
c'est une façon de lutter contre toutes
les discriminations qu'elles soient
forts qu'on soit gay noir av
une femme ou un handicap et enfin pour
moi c'est pareil quoi c'est un peu se
mettre du côté des minorités
le paris football gay entre 2003 et 2015
ce club a braqué le projecteur sur
l'homophobie dans le foot sujet alors
peu abordée dans l'équipe
une moitié de joueurs hétéro l'autre au
bout le paris foot gay en oeuvre sur le
terrain et dans les tribunes
il sensibilise le public et les clubs il
tente de faire comprendre le poids de
ces mots qui blessent supporters joueurs
un dirigeant il veut blesser un
adversaire il va sous-entendre qu'il est
homosexuel et des [ __ ]
du jeu comme une tablette etc ça veut
dire que l'or est clairement pour
blesser quelqu'un il suffit donc c'est
une insulte aux mots égale faible pour
en finir avec ce discours les joueurs
professionnels homosexuels pourraient
prendre la parole il sauf quatre gains
c'est un tabou ultime dans le foot c'est
mal vu
c'est ce qu'explique dominique bodin
sociologue et auteur du livre
l'homosexualité dans le sport de haut
niveau ils ont une certaine peur à être
reconnus comme des homosexuels et que
finalement s'ils sont improductifs sur
le terrain ils vont être traité de
[ __ ] ou ça sera la faute de tous les
homosexuels de france et navarre en
tabou pour les sportifs insultes dans
les tribunes et des instances sportives
que font-elles en 2008
la ligue de football professionnel s'est
saisie du problème
elle a rédigé une charte contre
l'homophobie
je voudrais que le football soit
exemplaire en termes de lutte toutes les
formes de discriminations quelles
qu'elles soient seules dix clubs
professionnels l'avait signé et quand
bien même la charte ne prévoyait pas de
sanction un sentiment d'impunité règne
dans les tribunes aujourd'hui encore
selon un sondage du journal l'équipe
67% des français attendent des sanctions
pour faire cesser ces champs mais ils
sont aussi 61 % à estimer qu'ils
relèvent plus de l'insultent que de
l'homophobie
[Musique]